Well,
like I said,
we're going to try something.
Um,
this is actually something I wrote in Nashville with a couple of guys that I
don't know if it's ever going to come to fruition or anything or I'm not sure if
it's going to,
if it will ever be on one of my records.
But I figured let's try something like that.
Do something new.
I don't even know what this caught.
I think this is called a,
it ain't easy
with the Superman
Scott off from the stitches.
No,
my hands.
But Sam
shanking other hand
when no kind.
Some town.
Hey Z.
Oh
hey.
Z
China
stock.
Hey Z.
Aha.
Wow.
This picture frame.
Okay.
Yeah.
This shit a photo graph
made me laugh
at him.
Now I'll go home.
Fine.
Hey Z,
some town waiting as the hottest spot
you.
Oh,
we'll keep following
challenge from their stock.
Cytel away.
My new little more work on that one.
But please stop judging yourself that she was beautiful.
Everybody jump around from town to town
slash gown
rats they snatch out.